please welcome the filmmakers of dreams
awake kevin gordon and rebecca Meredith
wow this these last few days have been
absolutely surreal this is a tremendous
honor and we first and foremost want to
thank the Academy this has been a
wonderful experience and I think in
addition to being a tremendous honor
it's also been an amazing encouragement
to us as student filmmakers to continue
doing the work that we're doing so we
really really appreciate that we also
want to thank our program at Stanford
University the MFA documentary film and
video program there are some amazing
people there Dan pray with Jamie Meltzer
Johnny Simon's the technical staff
marker banach Christian gains Lee and
our other fourteen students who just
play a crucial role in the development
of our films and also our development as
filmmakers I want to thank my mother and
and Omar Romero and Jason Renault who
are here in support of me and also all
the friends and family who are back home
rooting for me and hoping that I don't
trip on the way up to the stage and I
just I can't thank all of these people
enough for helping me be here and
helping me believe in myself and and the
work that we're doing
um they asked us to do that we put the
finishing touches on this film just a
few days before the submission deadline
and really just sent it in as a why not
kind of attitude so this is just
absolutely amazing when my sister saw
the film she started to cry but she was
pregnant at the time so we didn't know
if it was the film or the hormones but I
guess it's the film for a large part I'd
really like to thank my family my sister
Lauren my brother-in-law Neal have been
incredible support and provide a lot of
feedback over the years my brother Byron
and my sister-in-law Lynn s who provided
support from afar and my parents
especially who are in the audience
tonight when I gave up on my lifelong
plans to be a lawyer and told them I was
going to pick up documentary filmmaking
they were naturally skeptical but
they've given me nothing then their
complete support so I thank them for
that as well as all my friends back home
and most importantly we want to thank
Doroteo Garcia the subject of our film
was just an incredibly inspiring
individual and it was an honor to be
able to share his poetry in his words
with other people and we'd also like to
thank the countless immigrants like him
who's amazing stories and contributions
to our society often go unnoticed thank
you